you mentioned stepping out it's so hard
for people to remove themselves from
their own situation and try to look at
it from like an outside point of view
yeah something I got on my side though
too and I got good people around me that
want to see me win yeah because they
know if I win they win
yes I feel like it's it's uh you know
that's part of growing up too man it's
like you because you're always gonna
have like a biased opinion on what's
going on because you're in it but if you
could just look at it from like how it
looks like from the outside like you you
know a lot of people make short-sighted
decisions because they don't do that
okay do you feel like um
nowadays you're kind of like a big homie
in L.A you know what I mean so
um do you find yourself like giving game
to artists that you see that you admire
that you might maybe see [ __ ] up or
moving like a way in which you might
just be able to be like hey let me give
you some game real quick type [ __ ] off
top most definitely uh give game a lot
it's just oh
you know I apply it
but is you gonna use it though yeah like
I might tell you about it but are you
gonna like listen yeah like I'm not
really into wasting my breath because
for your energy all my energy no so
uh
I sort of picked certain times when to
speak it otherwise you're just trying to
hear yourself speak like an old head
just trying to hear yourself talk right
you know sometimes being Wise It's not
saying nothing at all feel me yeah so
sometimes you just gotta pick the
winning right time to say it in the
right time to speak I just you know so
like you know I'll pop it a little bit
you know get my game but you know you
gotta
know how to give it though I'm saying
and win and win exactly
you know now and being a big homie and
being like you know the evening some
[ __ ] like my little brothers I get mad
too
and I lose sometimes I could lose my
cool and jump out of character too I'm
I'm happy you know I'm human too so
you know I [ __ ] up players [ __ ] up but
at the end of the day like it's about
you know recovering and just like hey
you know what being man enough and be
like hey look man I [ __ ] up it you
know this is how I should have came you
know what I'm saying so being a big
homie like
I had to you know I got to take on those
certain roles when I was younger I was
just like I don't give a [ __ ] right here
right right you feel me like I don't
care like they got my bad but now that
I'm older I realize that people
um and not just older just wiser I
realize that people have to like like
people have to understand you
you can't just be out here popping [ __ ]
and you just look like a you know an old
head right it's not cool like I know how
we used to like yeah when people gotta
respect you if you're if like you said
if you don't always speak when you do
speak it carries more weight true you
know what I mean and they also have to
like respect you to listen for sure you
know what I mean like you just can't
pull put your arm around some young kid
that you just saw on Instagram hey man
you [ __ ] up bro [ __ ] out of here bro
yeah